du président de la république à georges
clemenceau soixante dix ans après la
france se souvient
49 points une victoire sans appel du
quinze de france sur la roumanie un bon
test à deux mois du tournoi des cinq
nations pour les finalistes de la coupe
du monde
apprendre à prendre pour la première
fois en france on organise l'espace de
réactivation des mécanismes du cerveau
les résultats sont encourageants
les pubs de grande bretagne pourront
rester ouverts toute la journée sans
interruption au printemps prochain
enquête à londres sur cette révolution
qui va faire couler beaucoup de guinness
le retour de michel boujenah au
music-hall tout seul et sans couffin
vous n'êtes à l'affiché de l'olympia
pour trois semaines et en direct ce soir
dans le journal d'antenne 2
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés dans toutes les
communes de france et à paris au pied de
l'arc de triomphe les cérémonies du 11
novembre était placée cette année sous
le signe du 70e anniversaire de l'année
1917 1917 fut à la fois une année
d'affrontements et d'espoir marquée par
les terribles combats du chemin des
dames
aujourd'hui sur les champs elysées
l'émotion était grande pour six anciens
combattants de la grande guerre
françois corner laurent boussier celui
ci n'est pas un vrai poids lui mais
c'était une façon pour les jeunes
générations de soldats de rendre hommage
en ce 11 novembre aux grands anciens de
14 18 il était en effet plusieurs
centaines ce matin combattants des deux
guerres qui ont déchiré l'europe venu
rendre hommage aux côtés du président de
la république au soldat inconnu sous
l'arc de triomphe
1914 1918 apocalypse d'un début de
siècle sur la terre de france des morts
des blessés des héros comme maurice
coquillard décoré à l'âge de 90 ans ce
matin avec cinq de ses camarades de la
légion d'honneur maurice coquillard nous
vous faisons chevalier de la légion
d'honneur
de l'émotion certes pour la
commémoration du 69ème anniversaire de
l'armistice de la grande guerre
des souvenirs des confidences consignées
dans un carnet jaunies que l'on fait
lire exceptionnellement dans un matin
d'automne
70 ans plus tard un président de la
république et un premier ministre
cérémonie du souvenir également à la
clairière de l'armistice présidée par
andré giraud accueilli ici par philippe
marini à tous au maire de compiègne de
l'émotion également dans ce haut lieu et
rencontres avec les anciens avant la
signature du livre d'or dans le wagon de
l'armistice à rethondes
cet après midi en vendée hommage très
remarquée du président de la république
à georges clemenceau et au maréchal de
lattre de tassigny françois mitterrand a
notamment déclaré
rien ne se fait sans la volonté d'un
homme capable de signifier la volonté
d'un peuple
jean-michel mercurol mouilleron en
pareds une petite bourgade de vent et
qui vit naître deux héros de chacune des
deux guerres mondiales
georges clemenceau le père la victoire
de 17 et jean de lattre de tassigny le
guerrier victorieux de 40 cars célébré
ici lui en novembre signifier pour
françois mitterrand salué des fils de
france et en dépit de leurs traditions
politiques opposées sur chacun incarner
la volonté nationale devant le péril
une manière aussi en évoquant clemenceau
de souligner la difficulté qu'il ya
parfois à faire l'unanimité
il lui fallait toute une vie et combien
de combats l'on rit le nombreux combats
pour être reconnu par la patrie elle
toute entière
c'est le sort de ceux qui marquent leur
temps à bretton on ne peut pas choisir
la route escarpée des grands choix en
plaisant à tout le monde un jour d'union
de souvenirs en terre vendéenne monsieur
que l'état y était
payé par des parures philippe maître et
philippe de villiers un jour audi ou les
élus vendéens furent pas rappeler que
clemenceau avait déjà fouettant de pézan
par des fuites appelé au gouvernement
pour rassembler les portes de la
victoire à paris journée de
commémoration également pour le
président lee tianan le président
chinois a profité du 11 novembre pour
déposer une gerbe au mur des fédérés au
cimetière du père lachaise à paris avant
de faire une petite escapade dans les
rues de la capitale
au programme notre dame et la tour
eiffel le dirigeant chinois s'est
également arrêtée dans le xiiie
arrondissement où a vécu l'ancien
premier ministre chinois tout en maille
de 1922 à 1924 acte symbolique de la
part du président chinois car en chine
le culte de la personnalité s'est
considérablement estompée ces derniers
temps le village de mao tsé toung n'est
plus un lieu de pèlerinage depuis
longtemps seule la musique pourrait à
l'extrême rigueur être celle des années
reportage christian héraud claude
hudelot lecteurs ont bien changé il ya
quelques années danser le rock et de
plus sous la statue de mao était un vrai
sacrilège ses ouvriers employés
techniciens sont venus à shaoshan le
temps d'un week end comme on va au mont
saint michel
il est vrai que mao a consacré sa vie à
la révolution il ya commis des fautes
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la chine
dans l'avenir j'espère que la chine sera
plus riche et plus développés que les
pays européens à deux pas la gare
construite spécialement pour les
visiteurs venus par millions depuis les
années 50
aujourd'hui les touristes étrangers se
font rares et l'ont pris le riz sur son
parking
au fond la maison natale de mode c'est
tout c'est le temps de la moisson
d'automne les journaliers embauché pour
battre le riz s'activent
je gagne 900 yuans par an je travaille
beaucoup je gagne bien plus tard
j'aimerais devenir commerçant de porcs
qui compte pour moi c'est gagner de
l'argent jadis des maoïstes bon teint et
les touristes venaient se recueillir
pieusement aujourd'hui des visiteurs
chinois prennent encore la photo
souvenir à shaoshan le petit commerce
des breloques et des reliques fonctionne
toujours
on y vendait mao mais aussi jésus
ida et les porte bonheur de toujours la
nostalgie maoïste n'est plus ce qu'elle
était en union soviétique on vient
d'apprendre que le patron du parti
communiste de moscou a été limogé
monsieur boris elstine cessons donc que
nous allons découvrir sur ces images
était un proche de michael gorbatchev
mais manifestement les deux hommes
avaient du mal à se comprendre ces
derniers temps georges bortoli c c'est
un nouveau coup de poing sur la table de
devenir élève dans votre chauffe 20-10
gens que boris eltsine était un peu le
singe en bouche d'or du kremlin il
disait tout haut ce que d'autres pensent
tout bas à savoir que les réformes
économiques l'amélioration du niveau de
vie gay soviétique ça va bien maintenant
le 21 octobre au cours d'une réunion
orageuse du comité central il était allé
jusqu'à offrir sa démission alors on l'a
prise au mot il s'en va il s'en va le
poste clé de patron du parti communiste
pour moscou poste-clé évidemment parce
que quelqu'un la capitale contrôlent
largement de paix passe dans les mains
de monsieur eickhoff qui lui aussi comme
si elles signent a fait son chemin dans
l'ombre de monsieur corbacho donc à
première vue monsieur gorbatchev me paie
rien mais c'est tout de même un aspect
un aspect sympathique du goba
chauvinisme qui a pris 1 cuil
l'appétit de réformes rapides l'appétit
de tout dire disons que monsieur
gorbatchev au lait cartonne chez helsinn
met de l'eau dans son vin et que la
pérestroïka irad d'ange sur un rythme un
peu plus lent
merci georges ammann fin du sommet des
états arabes en toile de fond une image
celle de la réconciliation entre les
présidents syrien et irakien en
perspective l'impact de cette
réconciliation sur le conflit en irak la
guerre du golfe ce soir à l'heure des
communiqués disons que les états arabes
condamne
rang et laisse chaque pays libre de
renouer avec l'egypte un compromis qui
devrait déboucher sur des mesures
concrètes
jean-marc il use une fois n'est pas
coutume le monde arabe n'a pas cherché
au sommet la manne à se réfugier dans
l'incantation le feu était dans la
maison
cette fois ci il ne venait pas d' israël
mais d'iran et grâce au réalisme
politique du roi hussein la vingtaine de
chefs d'état et de délégations réunies
dans la capitale jordanienne ont préféré
les petits pas concret aux grandes
envolées sans lendemain pas de pacte de
défense anti iranien mais l'iran est
nommément condamné pour son occupation
le territoire irakien et son refus
d'appliquer le cessez-le-feu des nations
unies pas de véritable réconciliation
politique entre syrie et l'irak
mais à amman le dialogue a pu reprendre
entre les frères ennemis du monde arabe
en contrepartie il a bien fallu
promettre à la syrie de ne pas rouvrir
la porte de la ligue arabe à l'egypte
exclu du fait de son traité avec israël
mais beau cadeau du roi hussein à son
ami le président égyptien moubarak ceux
qui ont rompu avec l'egypte pourront
renouer à leur guise leur relation avec
le plus grand pays arabe du monde voilà
personne ne crie au miracle mais pendant
trois jours les rancoeurs ont cédé le
pas au dialogue
reste à savoir bien sûr si les bonnes
résolutions dahmane pourront résister
aux vents contraires qui soufflent
toujours sur le golfe arabo persique
ainsi jean marc je viens de l'apprendre
à l'instant même les émirats arabes unis
rétablissent leurs relations
diplomatiques avec l'égypte
l'information vient d'être confirmée
voyons rapidement les autres nouvelles
de l'étranger avec isabelle staes
ensuite on parle d'économie et de
politique
l'arrestation de la bégum xia leaders
des manifestations anti-gouvernementales
d'hier elle est l'une des principales
figures de l'opposition au bangladesh à
dacca les affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre se
poursuivent et les violences policières
aurait fait 14 morts selon l'opposition
208 kilos de cocaïne une saisie record
pour les douanes d'état ni la
marchandise d'une valeur de 430 millions
de francs étaient cachés à bord d'un
bateau sa provenance la colombie
destination des pays bas
fin du voyage southampton puis personnes
ont été arrêtées
légère détente sur les marchés boursiers
après trois séances de repli wall street
et à la hausse pas de cotation
aujourd'hui à paris en revanche
effondrement à tokyo a signé
d'inquiétude
à la veille de la publication des
chiffres du commerce extérieur américain
valise piégée à l'aéroport de beyrouth
cet après-midi l'explosion a tué cinq
personnes et fait une soixantaine de
blessés l'armée syrienne est
immédiatement intervenu pour boucler le
secteur et puis en secteur chrétiens
français était blessé deux par balle il
s'appelle richard gimp elle il a été
retrouvé blessé dans sa voiture et
conduit à l'hôtel lieu on n'en sait pas
plus pour le moment
moderniser les entreprises c'est bien à
condition de les moderniser avec les
hommes c'est en gros la conclusion d'un
rapport remis hier au premier ministre
par antoine riboud le président du
groupe bsn
le grand problème expliqué antoine
riboud est de trouver un équilibre entre
le projet économique et le projet humain
pour illustrer ce rapport je vous
propose un reportage réalisé en corrèze
là bas c'est d'ailleurs une expérience
unique en europe
on donne une chance aux chômeurs à
travers le pays traduisez programme
d'enrichissement instrumental une
technique remue-méninges entre
guillemets patrick boitet l'écriture est
encore maladroite mais pour la première
fois depuis des années
certains de ces hommes reprennent le
style aux chômeurs longue durée en
majorité immigrées
ils planchent sur des exercices de
réflexion pure de difficulté croissante
un stage de deux cents heures le but est
ambitieux leur apprendre ou réapprendre
à mieux utiliser leur intelligence car
certains de ces chômeurs se montre
incapable de toute reconversion
simplement par manque de confiance en
leurs capacités intellectuelles le pays
programme d'enrichissement instrumental
permet de dépasser les blocages
existants à n'importe quel âge et
n'importe quel niveau on était danger
légine et puis on travaillait dur
on n'avait pas aucune chance on avait la
tête qui était vide et ce stage là ça
leur apporte quelque chose
l'intérêt essentiel c'est que ça rend
les gens plus intelligents
on a du recul maintenant on a travaillé
sur plusieurs stages on s'est aperçu que
les gens progresser vite et beaucoup
jusqu'à 20 points quotient intellectuel
ça me paraît important essentiel et
fondamental et ça remet en question
finalement les outils classiques de la
psychologie et cette pensée que
l'intelligence était figée
l'intelligence bouge évolue et on peut
la faire progresser
après le programme les chômeurs suivent
des stages de formation professionnelle
classique en général leurs résultats
sont bien supérieures à la moyenne
normale mieux préparer
intellectuellement
ils se sentent plus forts moralement au
fond du trou et ce stage m'a permis de
savoir où j'en étais de faire le point
beaucoup d'assurance et l'assurance
permet bien des choses
jean yves bernard commande désormais
douze personnes dans cette entreprise de
transport ancien comptable il n'a pas
hésité à changer de spécialité
on peut reparler strictement rien aux
transports et on va proposer ce stage en
entreprise et ça se passe très bien
enfin grâce aux pays qui donnent
confiance ce qui donne qui apporte une
ouverture sur n'importe quel
techniques de travail qu'on n'apprend
pas quelque chose bien spécifiques
on apprend à démonter le mécanisme de
l'intelligence qui nous fait accomplir
n'importe quelle tâche à l'heure des
mutations technologiques
la qualification devient toujours plus
nécessaire de nombreuses formations se
révèle périmés au bout de quelques
années le pays lui prêtant à la
souplesse
alors bien sûr ce n'est pas le remède
miracle au chômage mais en redonnant
espoir et énergie aux stagiaires le pays
leur permet sans doute de mieux vivre
cette période douloureuse
la politique jacques toubon secrétaire
général du rpr est ce soir l'invité de
l'heure de vérité en direct sur antenne
2 au menu économie avec la tourmente
autour de la bourse et des
privatisations les affaires dont on a
beaucoup parlé et la perspective des
présidentielles
quel est le sujet qui est prioritaire
pour vous c'est tout bon je pense que
naturellement la situation économique
mondiale et qui a des conséquences
directes en france est une préoccupation
pour tous et je suis sûr qu'on en
parlera ce soir
bien sûr aussi de la politique du
gouvernement et en particulier des
privatisations dont vous venez de parler
la bourse c'est le marché des actions
comme tous les marchés il obéit à la loi
de l'offre et la demande quand il ya
beaucoup plus d'acheteurs que de
vendeurs sa baisse et celle inverse
candia plus de vendeurs je crois qu'il
faut aussi voir que les actions ce sont
des parts de sociétés d'entreprises qui
vont bien et je crois que c'est ça qu'on
parlera ce soir parce qu'il faut se
tourner vers l'avenir en matière de
privatisations vous savez que tout le
monde ne partage pas l'optimisme forcené
de monsieur balladur est ce que ça vous
inquiète
optimus deux forcenés je crois que c'est
une expression très forte surtout
cantonné le tempérament sage et
raisonnable
edouard balladur il a dit d'ailleurs le
premier
l'été dernier il ya plus d'un an en
présentant la loi sur les privatisations
qu'on ferait les privatisations en
fonction de l'état du marché
eh bien c'est ce qu'on va faire alors
y'a pas de quoi s'affoler il n'y a pas
de quoi non plus monter des procès
politiques
en deux mots j'ai lu dans les journaux
ce matin que vous n'avez plus besoin de
consulter le premier ministre pour
savoir ce qu'ils pensent et s'il attend
c'est presque de la télépathie
est ce que le premier ministre accorde
de l'importance au sondage le premier
ministre accorde comme tous les hommes
politiques une certaine importance aux
sondages parce qu'il sait qu'il traduise
instantanément des tendances de
l'opinion
non je vous pouvez les derniers sondages
sont pas spécialement bon henri sannier
je ne supposait pas que vous me posiez
cette question pour une autre raison je
voyais donc simplement il sait aussi
comme moi que les sondages
à cinq mois par exemple d'une élection
c'est un peu prématuré alors nous
verrons bien
merci il ya tout à l'heure 20h30 les
téléspectateurs peuvent d'ores et déjà
vous poser des questions en appelant svp
aux 47 87 11 11 précédé du 16 et du 1,6
et vous appelez de la province on
enchaîne avec une information pratique
depuis hier la vignette est en vente
dans tous les bureaux de tabac
une vignette qui fait allègrement ses 30
ans et qui fait le bonheur successives
des caisses de l'état et des 95
départements français en 1986 la
vignette a rapporté près de 10 milliards
de francs
un vrai petit pactole alain us qui la
télévision était là pour filmer
l'événement du 30 juin 1956 la vente de
la première vignette automobile cette
année là trois millions sept cent mille
véhicules quatre roues à moteur
circulait en france les propriétaires
allez devoir acheter un petit carré de
papier et le coller sur leur pare-brise
il coûtait 9000 francs de l'époque pour
un véhicule de cinq à sept chevaux
reportages diffusés en noir et blanc le
commentateur du précisé qu'à la vignette
et est de couleur bleu il ajouta que
l'argent était prélevé en faveur des
personnes âgées joie des personnes âgées
indifférence de leur petit compagnon à
quatre pattes il eu raison de ne pas se
réjouir de cette faveur leurs vieux
maître ne vire pas longtemps la couleur
des 271 millions de francs récoltés
cette année là 1965 documents que l'on
peut dette et grâce à la coiffure de la
buraliste le nombre de vignettes vendu
dépassent les 10 millions
elle rapporte 700 millions de francs à
l'état
dix ans plus tard 1975 14 millions de
vignettes vendu les recettes s'envole
près de 2 milliards de francs toujours
plus gourmands en 1983 le ministère des
finances tentant en vain de faire payer
la vignette aux motards il faut attendre
1984 et la loi de décentralisation pour
que le produit de la vignette se dirige
vers les conseils généraux 1986 27
millions 700 mille exemplaires de ces
autocollants très spéciaux sont vendus
soit deux fois plus de véhicules qu'il
ya 15 ans les rapports près de 10
milliards de francs département ce qui
représente en moyenne 10 % de leurs
recettes
petite révolution en grande bretagne à
partir de l'an prochain les débits de
boisson anglais et gallois resteront
ouverts l'après midi incroyable mais
vrai jusqu'à présent c'était la loi de
1915 qui était toujours en vigueur
il faut dire qu'à cette époque là en
pleine guerre mondiale les ouvriers des
usines d'armement manifestaient un
sérieux penchant pour les pintes de
bière ce qui occasionnait parait-il des
défaillances dans les productions d'obus
soixante dix ans après les temps
changent philippe harrouard cela n'a
l'air de rien mais on parle ici de
révolution
les pubs ne seront plus fermé l'après
midi à partir du printemps prochain
la loi en préparation depuis dix ans
vient d'être voté 2 193 députés pour 87
qu'on en grande bretagne le peuple c'est
une institution incontournable
il y en a soixante quinze mille dans
tout le pays dans ces maisons public
traduction littérale les anglais se
retrouvent tous les jours chaque
quartier chaque rue à son pub avec ses
habitués fidèles
pour raisons de guerre en 1915 le
gouvernement décide que les pubs ne sera
ouvert que de 11 heures à 15 heures et
de 17 heures 30 à 23 heures
depuis les choses sont restées figées
anachronique entende étant ici pas
question de changer disait sont là des
opposants les plus virulents et dans les
associations de lutte contre
l'alcoolisme
finalement on tente une expérience en
écosse les pubs étant ouvert la journée
on ne constate aucun regain d'alcoolisme
aucune diminution non plus donc feu vert
les consommateurs sont contents bien sûr
les patrons de pub aussi encore que le
loyer augmentera des taxes locales
augmentera les gages aux montra alors le
voit son pôle pour les clients dont le
consommateur ça ne voit aux trois prix
remarquer que les peuples c'est quand
même une bonne industrie si l'on
considère que les britanniques doivent
chaque jour 13 millions de litres de
bière
mais si on considère la consommation
d'alcool toutes catégories confondues
cela représente deux fois moins que ce
que boivent les français
chez nous on trinque à la victoire du
quinze de france et oui 49 à 3 l'équipe
de france de rugby n'a pas fait de
détail cet après midi face à la roumanie
le match se déroulait taz gens meurent
et oui et les français l'ont largement
emporté surtout que cet après-midi la
distribution des pruneaux n'était pas
sur le terrain mais pour les tribunes
bien au contraire d'ailleurs puisque
deux exemples touche roumaine la balle
est mal exploité l'ouvreur alexandre ou
tentent de dégager son camp
blancco est à la réception pour une de
ces actions dont il a le secret petit
coup de pied pour lui-même il évite
trois adversaires et aux une balle d'été
a pas très agitée un vrai régal
autre exemple cette percée de berbizier
sur une base sortie de mêlée ouverte une
course de 40 m un relais avec janick
berbizier à nouveau à l'intérieur et
enfin andrieu pour un nouvel essai
transformé france et la france malgré
l'absence de certains types titulaire
n'a rien perdu de son repli depuis la
coupe du monde et c'est encourageant
c'est pas mal revenons quelques instants
sur le problème de jeu ni longo accusé
de dopage jani a décidé de se battre
contre eux si je ne suis pas dopé j'ai
pour moi la conscience d'une
professionnelle scène par cette phrase
elle coupe court à tout dialogue reste
néanmoins la surprise de ce contrôle
positif difficilement compréhensible
effectué lors d'un record que l'on
pourrait qualifier d'entraînement
surprise dans l'utilisation même du
produit
l'éphédrine est un très vieux médicament
très aisément décelables
et comme l'expliqué le docteur porte de
la fédération il n'est vraiment dopants
qu'utiliser à l'état pur et à très
fortes doses ce qui n'était évidemment
pas le cas ici
surprise à l'égard de la championne elle
même contrôlée plus d'une cinquantaine
de fois elle n'a jamais été soupçonné de
quoi que ce soit et le président de la
fédération lui-même loin d'être un
inconditionnel de jeannie longo avoue sa
stupéfaction
avec tous ses défauts nous dit il est
lavé et elle a toujours à mes yeux tant
que je n'ai pas d'explication la grande
qualité d'être honnête
les explications nous les aurons
peut-être demain à 11 heures à la mairie
de grenoble où jeannie longo devant la
presse donnant une conférence mais d'ici
là attendant après le score les feux de
la rampe là encore il est question de
performance vous allez le voir michel
boujenah fait sa rentrée au music-hall
première ce soir à l'olympia
après le triomphe de trois hommes et un
couffin au cinéma boujenah revient dans
un spectacle qui allie humour et
tendresse boujenah s'interroge au micro
d'antenne 2 au jour
ici maxxo boutboul un direct de
l'olympia et j'ai le plaisir ce soir
d'interviewer michel boujenah j'ai
essayé de vous poser des questions pas
trop longue
parce qu'en général je pose des
questions tellement longue que le titre
n'a pas le temps de répondre dites-moi
michel boujenah c'est un nouveau
spectacle ça parle de quoi
et ça parle de la solitude du désordre
amoureux 2 c mais ça faisant quoi ce
pack sur un thème assez tristes parce
que vous avez déjà j'ai envie de me
suicider déjà est à mon avis le
présentateur du journal aussi les
téléspectateurs aussi ça vous n'avez pas
écrit monsieur boutboul
c'est triste mais c'est souvent avec les
choses près ce qu'on fait rire
une autre question de question bloque le
succès vous at il changé et est ce que
vous comptez garder votre accent tout le
temps l'accent que vous avez immo donc
si je vous disais entre nous ou boutboul
que j'ai jamais la grosse tête du touch
l'inventeur temps en temps j'ai la
grosse tête cédric soul était
heureusement sans abri 10 amazon des
fois je rentre à la maison je n'ai pas
compris
j'arrive pas que je défonce la porte à
la tête et je tends de joux du mois que
ce que je suis le plus beau le plus
grand et puis j'ai toujours à ce moment
là un copain vieux copain qui me disent
on verrait de tension je te plaît chat
téléspectateurs c'était donc maxxo
boutboul pour antenne 2 envoyé spécial à
l'olympia à vous les studios
ici les studios michel boujenah bonsoir
ça c'était des différents et là
maintenant vous êtes en direct à cinq
minutes des trois coups alors on pense à
quoi avant l'ouverture du rideau
ben on pense à tous les gens qu'on a
embêté pendant des mois et des mois pour
arriver à ce jour là on pense aux gens
que vous entendez pas là mais il ya le
murmure des raids derrière le rideau là
c'est la plus belle musique du monde et
vous allez dans la salle là je crois
savoir c'est un rythme oui absolument
regarde un peu on est un peu voyeur
parce qu'après c'est les autres qui sont
voyeur alors on profite un peu plus
qu'on voit les têtes on a peur on veut
se rassurer tous avaient regardé qui
était au premier rang ce soir là non je
regarde pas le premier rang je veux pas
le regarder je veux pas le regarder
premier arrêté de me poser cette
question c'est une bonne question elle
était rapide
ah oui non c'est fou parce que
évidemment on a très très peur de qui
sur qui on va tomber au premier rang
ouais on meurt de trouille de ça parce
que si jamais quand le rideau s'ouvre on
tombe sur une tête qu'on n'aime pas
quand on regarde
mirant on peut perdre la concentration
on est foutu non ça peut être très
dangereux et je veux pas vous déranger
et chamboulé vos idées là juste avant de
rentrer sur scène mais vous allez
rentrer comment la tout à l'heure vous
le montrer en direct là vous êtes déjà
sur scène cette partie pourquoi génial
attention parce que j'ai pas mes ailes
sur moi parce que je rentre avec dlc
puis je rentre attendait ne quittez pas
j'arrive français c'est bien alors
attendez là c'est vraiment du direct
loyer il est derrière le rideau rouge et
il fonce je pense que ça va donner
c'est bon comme ça
merci à vous tous de l'autre côté merci
et ils ont payé
voilà j'attire être à la hauteur et on
croise les doigts pour vous il reste
monsieur ceni n'oubliez pas de croiser
lui reste dans la poubelle comme ça
merci et à bientôt
ce qu'on lit sur la deux camps et les
instants les pronostics du tiercé
pierrette brès avant ça je vous donne
des résultats du tiercé qui s'est
disputé cet après midi à saint cloud lui
fallait jouer dans l'ordre le 7 le 14 et
le 11
une combinaison qui rapporte 2008 175
francs pour 5 francs et dans un ordre
différent 575 prend pas très bien payé
on enchaîne avec les pronostics du
tiercé pour du quartier pour nous car
tes dires ces puces qui se courra dans
un très beau steeple-chase le prix
violon ii demain après-midi sur
l'hippodrome d'auteuil alors cette
course se déroule sur 4400 mètres à
l'empreinte un parcours très difficile
alors est ce la difficulté des obstacles
à sauter la longueur du parcours ou
alors la formule un handicap
toujours utile c'est que les ventes d
éventuels concurrents et bien ont
préféré s'abstenir c'est à dire les
meilleurs ne seront pas là et il nous
reste plus qu'un petit lot assez maigre
de douze chevaux
alors bien évidemment seydoux chevaux
sont tous des spécialistes ils sont âgés
de 5 ans ils connaissent la musique
comme l'ont dit ce sont de vieux
routiers et bien personnellement par
mieux voici maintenant le pronostic que
je vous propose de jouer voici mes
préférés avec en tête cavaleur le numéro
6 suivi les aveux de carvi rôle un os
annick le 2 quittez pas ce numéro 9
très garon le 4l fan numéro 11 et
bandana mots le numéro 12 6 1 2 9 4 11
et 12 on enchaîne avec la météo une
météo synonyme de 2
j'ai tout à fait les vents vont se
déchaîner demain souffler bride abattue
en particulier sur la bretagne
pourquoi parce que deux perturbations
vont se succéder de ma alors une
première sera situé sur l'alsace les
alpes et le massif central à la
mi-journée à peu près derrière son
passage elle reste elle laissera un ciel
tout à fait tourmenté où alterneront
éclaircies passages nuageux et averses
une nouvelle perturbation arrivera en
même temps à peu près sur la bretagne et
là les vents souffleront fort restaurant
de soufflé par rafales de 130 kilomètres
à l'heure
en revanche ce sera le calme dans le
midi et sur la corse que des
températures c'est la relative douceur
c'est à dire 11 devrait à peu près
partout sur la moitié nord 18 à nice est
toujours 20 en corse et demain jeudi 12
novembre
pensez à christian prochain rendez-vous
d'information 23h30 avec aubry et de
l'air demain n'oubliez pas télématin à
partir de 6h45
c'est edith cresson ministre du commerce
extérieur l'ancien ministre du commerce
extérieur qui sera l'invitée mes quatre
vérités
merci d'être fidèle à antenne 2 et à
demain bonsoir
e